[Music]
are you kidding me
oh
did this dip [ __ ] really show up in full
cosplay mode this is the guy waller's
giving us i told you she's [ __ ] us
she's not [ __ ] us is that an eagle in
his backseat
she's [ __ ] us
hey
scooch
why are you in your costume
costume this is a uniform and it's brand
new so i'm gonna stretch it out make it
more comfortable before going to mission
maybe i'm stupid but why would you even
want to wear that on a mission a bright
red shirt and white pants aren't exactly
conducive to lurking in the shadows
people see this uniform and strikes fear
in their hearts what people the other
people at the village people try out why
is there a bald eagle in your car that's
equally you guys work without me
eagley is your pet eagle yeah
is your dog named doggie
all right do you have a daughter named
daughtery
jealous of a guy's pedigo much
[Music]
the revolution will be televised
i'm gonna grind these bombs to make my
bread whoa nelly how am i the bad guy
do you like this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is this a walk of shame
and just like that
why are you in your costume this is a
uniform
venus and serena gonna shake up this
world
the future i can see it
[Music]
after all these years back to the matrix
you